Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
surfshark VPN más sobre esto En un
momento
[Música]
Donald Trump vuelve al circo electoral
y no se lo vuelve sino que el
expresidente Trump está desatado sigue
con la teoría del fraude electoral del
2020 y al mejor estilo golpista ha
llegado a pedir que no se acate la
Constitución de los Estados Unidos de
América arrojamos los resultados de las
elecciones presidenciales de 2020 y
declaramos al ganador justo o celebramos
una nueva elección un fraude masivo de
este tipo y magnitud admite la rescisión
de todas las normas reglamentos y
artículos incluso los que se encuentran
en la Constitución Donald Trump Donald
Trump le da absolutamente igual que los
tribunales y las investigaciones
formales tiraran por tierra su teoría
del fraude el expresidente parece querer
situarse por encima de las normas las
leyes y la propia Constitución Si estas
no sirven a sus intereses Entonces no
sirven para nada Donald que debemos
poner fin a todas las normas reglamentos
y artículos incluso los que se
encuentran en la Constitución para
revocar las elecciones de 2020 Esa fue
su opinión el 6 de enero y sigue siendo
su opinión hoy ninguna persona honesta
puede negar ahora que Trump es un
enemigo de la Constitución lichini la
Constitución es más importante que
cualquier presidente fin de la historia
y lo más Hubo un tiempo en el que se
justificaba este comportamiento sus
insultos y las constantes mentiras
aludiendo a Que bueno que en última
instancia todo esto era parte del show
una forma de expoliar a las masas y
destacar un discurso político sin miedo
y sometimiento a lo políticamente
correcto
Espero ya os hemos dicho que Trump está
desatado Así que ahora nos podemos
encontrar con noticias como esta gran
expresa su apoyo a los asaltantes del
Capitolio mientras continuaba abrazando
a grupos extremistas el expresidente
está diciendo que la gente que participó
en el Capitolio fue tratada de forma
injusta dice que su campaña está
apoyando a algunos de los principales
acusados e incluso ha prometido indultos
Si regresa a la casa blanca y ojo que
puede querer convertir ese fatídico 6 de
enero en uno de los Pilares de su
campaña sería una forma de mantener su
denuncia contra el sistema al mismo
tiempo que se crea su propio escudo de
fanáticos activistas muy radicalizados
que pueden jugar un peso importante en
las primarias republicanas esto
explicaría también por qué el
expresidente comenzó su nueva campaña
política cenando con El rapero
antisemita kanye West y con nick Fuentes
Un conocido neonazi que estuvo en el
mitin de Trump previo al asalto al
Capitolio Cuanto más radicalizadas estén
sus bases mejor que mejor
[Música]
trampa contribuido a normalizar
comportamientos que en cualquier otro
momento hubieran resultado inadmisibles
Y eso ha sido malo para todos sin
embargo un momento nuestra intención no
es hacer un juicio sobre el expresidente
sino ver por qué en esta ocasión las
cosas pueden ser totalmente diferentes
Trump puede tener muy complicado hacerse
con las primarias el expresidente está
perdiendo apoyos a toda velocidad y de
momento ni siquiera es el gran favorito
entre los votantes republicanos será que
la estrella de Donald Trump se está
apagando atentos
Pero antes un momento dejadme que os
hable de internet como ya sabéis
internet está lleno de hackers y de
páginas que nos meten cookies por todos
los lados por no hablar de cada vez más
restricciones geográficas queréis poder
ver contenido de cualquier país sin
ningún tipo de bloqueo y además navegar
por internet con seguridad pues no lo
penséis más usad una VPN como surfshark
VPN el tema de la ciberseguridad lo
toman muy en serio de hecho surfshark es
la primera VPN comercial que puede
presumir de tener servidores en más de
100 países distintos pero no sólo eso
surfshark tiene una herramienta que se
llama Clean web que bloquea todos esos
pop Ups de propaganda peligrosos y por
si todo esto fuera poco con una misma
cuenta podrás registrar todos los
dispositivos que quieras por ejemplo
quieres navegar con seguridad desde tu
smart tv desde tu tablet tu teléfono tu
ordenador pues puedes meter todos ellos
en una misma cuenta de surf y lo mejor
de todo tienen una oferta muy especial
de navidad para toda la comunidad de
visualpolitik ahora mismo usando el
código politik acabado en K podréis
disfrutar de un 85% de descuento y 3
meses gratis y ahora continuemos con
nuestro vídeo de hoy
El ocaso de Trump
[Música]
la carrera política como líder
republicano de Donald Trump no comenzó a
que el 16 de junio de 2015 cuando Trump
anunció por primera vez su candidatura a
las primarias republicanas
people
to problems
the bringing crime de ripes no su
carrera comenzó algo Antes concretamente
el 19 de noviembre del 2012 pocos días
después de Que Barack Obama derrotara a
Meet rodney Trump registró como marca
ese conocido lema que dice make América
Great Again un lema electoral con el que
logró convertirse contra todo pronóstico
en el cuadragésimo quinto presidente de
los Estados Unidos de América gracias a
una enorme carambola electoral que le
permitió hacerse con los Estados
habitualmente demócratas de Pensilvania
Michigan y Wisconsin por un puñado de
votos fue una victoria por la mínima
pero ganó en aquel momento Trump parecía
capaz de lograr lo imposible hoy sin
embargo las cosas son completamente
distintas
y sabéis que podemos destacar tres
claves por las que Trump tendrá mucho
más difícil volver a repetir no ya como
presidente sino Incluso como candidato
republicano y Es que hoy el trampismo se
enfrenta a noticias como esta 7 de
diciembre de 2022 los demócratas amplían
la mayoría del senado después de ganar
la segunda vuelta de Georgia Georgia
tradicionalmente ha sido un feuda
republicano sin embargo biden lo ganó
contra todo pronóstico en 2020 y ahora
en las elecciones de mitad de mandato
los demócratas también han ganado la
carrera al senado en la segunda vuelta
de este estado que se celebra cuando un
candidato no supera el 50% de los votos
el demócrata raciel War nok derrotó a
herschelle walker un candidato protramp
incluso una gran Victoria política para
la administración biden y un duro
varapalo para la campaña de Trump
[Música]
Y es que veréis Walker ha sido en
Georgia el único candidato republicano
en las elecciones del 2022 en no lograr
la victoria las otras ocho elecciones
con circunscripción Estatal incluyendo
la del gobernador la del secretario del
estado y el fiscal general fueron
ganadas cómodamente Por los republicanos
es decir Walker fue la excepción y la
pregunta es qué diantres diferenció a
walker del resto de candidatos
republicanos pues entre otras cosas que
Walker era el único candidato trampista
de hecho el gobernador Brian kempe se
enfrentó al expresidente al defender que
las elecciones del 2020 fueron limpias
Brian Kent debe dimitir de su cargo es
un obstruccionista que se niega a
admitir que ganado en Georgia por mucho
también ganamos otros estados bisagra
Donald Trump en Twitter Claro que no se
trata solo de Georgia las elecciones de
mitad de mandato han supuesto una
dolorosa derrota para Trump
tal y como podéis ver en pantalla de los
16 candidatos a senador gobernador y
secretario de estado que formaban parte
del núcleo trampista en los Estados en
disputa que fueron ganados por biden y
que por tanto son vitales para las
aspiraciones republicanas en 2024 tan
solo dos consiguieron la victoria Y esto
es tan solo un pequeño ejemplo del mal
desempeño republicano en unas elecciones
de mitad de mandato que a priori le
serán favorables
de hecho los republicanos esperaban una
gran ola de victorias que sin embargo no
se produjo nunca los demócratas
ampliaron su influencia en el senado y
prácticamente empataron en la cámara de
representantes los resultados fueron
claros los candidatos colocados por
Trump muchos de ellos extremistas que
repiten las consignas del expresidente
tuvieron un desempeño pésimo las
derrotas de los candidatos puro Trump al
senado Blake Masters en Arizona Adam
laxalt en Nevada memet Oz en Pensilvania
y herscher walker en Georgia fueron
particularmente dolorosas y esto nos
lleva directamente a la primera clave de
por qué esta vez las cosas pueden ser
diferentes para el ex presidente puede
que te sorprenda pero Trump se ha
convertido en toda una máquina de perder
elecciones
ganó por la mínima en 2016 perdió en
2018 en 2020 y otra vez en 2022 si
dejamos atrás empezaremos a ganar las
elecciones si nos quedamos con
Seguiremos perdiendo las elecciones Así
es como lo veo Paul ryant político
republicano expresidente de la cámara de
representantes y candidato a la
vicepresidencia en 2016 sé que mucha
gente de nuestro partido adora al
expresidente Pero él es podemos decir el
beso de la muerte para los que quieran
ganar unas elecciones generales y en
algún momento Tendremos que seguir
adelante y buscar nuevos líderes que nos
lleven a la victoria metroni senador
republicano por Utah cuando en 2015
Trump anunció su candidatura el partido
venía de lograr una enorme ola
republicana que los había llevado a
conseguir 54 senadores
247 escaños en la cámara de
representantes y 31 gobernadores hoy
están mucho peor en todos los frentes
puede que te sorprenda pero la era de
Trump se ha saldado con mucho menos
poder para los repu
el expresidente fuera uno de los pocos
presidentes en no lograr la reelección
no fue algo casual de hecho hablamos de
un candidato relativamente impopular en
todas las encuestas su grado de
desaprobación supera de media el 55%
fijaos
[Música]
Y es que ya ni siquiera es el candidato
favorito para los republicanos espera
Cómo Sí sí fijaos una nueva encuesta
encuentra que ronda santis tiene una
ventaja de 7 puntos sobre Trump en las
primeras presidenciales de 2024 Claro
que esta no es la única clave que
explica por qué esta campaña se le puede
complicar y mucho al expresidente
el segundo motivo tiene que ver con que
vaya totalmente por libre hecho que
entre las filas republicanas está
empezando a despertar cierta
preocupación por ejemplo justo antes de
las elecciones de mitad de mandato Trump
puso en marcha una campaña contra una de
las grandes estrellas que hoy tiene el
partido republicano hablamos por
supuesto del gobernador de Florida ron
de santis un viejo Aliado que sin
embargo ahora ha cosechado una gran
Victoria en Florida y empieza a ser
relativamente Popular en todo el país
pues bien Trump viéndole las orejas al
lobo le ha puesto directamente en su
Diana y eso explica
como esta Trump se lanza la guerra
contra the santis y no se trata de un
caso aislado para nada
cada vez que un líder republicano no le
hace el juego Trump le pone en su Diana
cueste lo que cueste y suponga lo que
suponga para el partido el caso del
gobernador de Virginia glenn o lo que
está ocurriendo en Arizona son también
buenos ejemplos en este último caso y de
la mano de organizaciones como la
turning Point usa el trampismo ha
intentado purgar a todos los moderados y
a todos los candidatos de la vieja
guardia republicana en su lugar están
poniendo a candidatos mucho más
exaltados radicales y fieles a Trump que
entre otras cosas niegan que Estados
Unidos sea una democracia hablamos de un
grupo incontrolable que electoralmente
también son un desastre El caso es que
Trump va por libre y parece querer hacer
del partido republicano una organización
sumisa a su pleno servicio Como os
podéis imaginar está generando mucha
inquietud dentro del ala no trampista
del partido que sigue siendo claramente
mayoritaria pero aún aún no hemos
terminado
[Música]
la tercera clave tiene que ver con todos
los procesos judiciales a los que se
enfrenta el expresidente y ojo porque no
se trata de que tenga algún que otro
problemilla no a Trump los problemas
judiciales le llegan hasta el cuello
desde el robo de documentos secretos
sobre armas nucleares hasta su
participación en el asalto al Capitolio
o problemas Fiscales de todo tipo ni
siquiera es improbable que Trump termine
en el banquillo de los acusados de
momento a los pocos días de presentar su
candidatura ocurrió esto 6 de diciembre
de 2022 la organización Trump se declara
culpable de fraude fiscal penal en el
juicio de Nueva York Claro que esto es
solo la punta del iceberg Pues bien
Estas son las tres claves que hacen que
esta vez el expresidente no parta con
ninguna aureola de éxito y eso Por
supuesto tiene consecuencias
[Música]
[Aplausos]
por ejemplo cada vez son más y más los
republicanos que abogan por pasar página
y esto ocurre incluso entre algunas
conocidas figuras trampistas un
verdadero líder entiende cuando se ha
convertido en un pasivo un verdadero
líder entiende que es hora de salir del
escenario y los votantes nos han dado
ese mensaje muy claro Wilson Sears
vicegobernadora de Virginia su propio
vicepresidente que puso mucha distancia
de por medio tras el asalto al Capitolio
ya ha dejado Claro que no apoyará a
Trump ven sobre si votaría por trama en
2024 podría haber otra persona quien
preferiría más y ojo que este rechazo
incluye también a importantes donantes
del partido switcherman de Blackstone
dice que no apoyará la candidatura
presidencial de Donald Trump es hora de
que el partido republicano recurra una
nueva generación de líderes y Tengo la
intención de apoyar a uno de ellos En
las primarias presidenciales Stephen
switcherman fundador de Blackstone el
Mega donante del partido republicano que
en Griffin que puso 60 millones de
dólares para las campañas republicanas
del actual ciclo llamó a Trump tres
veces perdedor y dijo no debería
postularse para presidente pero no sólo
hablamos de políticos y donantes sino
también de los propios medios de
comunicación
[Música]
medios que tanto han apoyado Trump como
la Fox o el New York post ya están
poniendo tierra de por medio y sabéis
que creo que este es uno de esos
momentos en los que una imagen vale más
que mil palabras Así es como el New York
post ha comenzado a tratar a Trump y
sobre todo Así es como está empezando a
considerar sus alternativas ron de
santis el gobernador de Florida se está
convirtiendo en la nueva gran estrella
del partido republicano y si finalmente
decidiera dar el paso de presentarse a
las primarias esto podría suponer un
tremendo mazazo otro más para las
aspiraciones de Donald Trump por qué
veámoslo
[Música]
El verdugo de Trump
procedente de una familia de clase media
ron de santis estudió en Yale y en
Harvard sirvió en el ejército fue
abogado militar estuvo desplegado en
Irak ha sido congresista y ahora en su
reelección como gobernador de Florida ha
arrasado de Santi se hizo con casi el
60% de los votos en un estado que hasta
ahora era considerado competitivo para
los demócratas eso ya no será así de
santis cosechó incluso una ventaja de 15
puntos entre los votantes hispanos lo
que le valió ganar hasta en el condado
de miami-dade la primera vez que un
republicano lo consigue en las últimas
dos décadas sobre el gobernador de
Florida y sus posiciones políticas
haremos un vídeo específico muy pronto
aquí en visualpolitik así que ya sabéis
no olvide suscribiros si es que aún no
lo habéis hecho
[Música]
pero de momento lo que nos importa es
que hablamos de un tipo muy conservador
que según las encuestas ya es el
preferido por los votantes republicanos
y no sólo eso mientras que a nivel
nacional biden le saca 10 puntos a Trump
empata con the santis si finalmente
diera el paso de presentarse a las
primeras republicanas ese podría llegar
a suponer el final de las aspiraciones
de Trump Claro que todavía no está claro
que se presente pero como os hemos dicho
de todo eso y más hablaremos en un
próximo vídeo de momento turno para ti
crees que Trump será el candidato
republicano en 2024 crees que es una
buena idea que se presente o por contra
debería hacerse de una vez por todas a
un lado qué opinión tienes de Trump
déjanos tu respuesta abajo en los
comentarios y hablamos debate y ahora si
este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
No olvides darle al botón de like Muchas
gracias una vez más por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]